he's so funny how great is Moloch he's
such a nice guy and how funny is that
[ __ ]
so funny I'm telling you nobody works
harder nobody works harder
well hold my beer but such an yeah I
know he's such a good guy now now you
gave him little taste of wrestling will
hold now hold on now hold on there
before I was taught me and Brown were
tired I think this Friday night sorry oh
you know it wakes me up is what if I can
just pummel I couldn't believe it
no no that's how what you said hold on
I'm um he's getting ready to go out
onstage and when was it was it Saturday
or Friday Friday night and you know late
show Friday night your Energy's little
and Brennan just goes I want a wrestle I
was so tired why I'm in bed by 9:00
yeah and he goes to a little wrestling
and we started to wrestle now I've been
working under hooks and stuff like that
didn't really work on me because you put
your head in my chin I'll give you the
shrink arms yeah and then you got and
then I I tried I said why do you all see
the Kebede gameplan and I did I'd give
him a break a physical breakdown of how
could be he gets his opposed to the
floor and nobody does when you get you
caught my hips
you brought my hips in and then you
started to snake me slowly mmm like an
anaconda those are done your post
you took my post out and then you were
kind of lightly punching me in the face
and the head and I took your legs away
like khabib does and I said now and I
said you against the wall no this is a
cage yeah and I said now I'm gonna let
you work to get up Brian work to get up
yeah took my risk control like to BB and
then you you wrapped my legs that was
not funny that's what could be dust yeah
I gave you the key that's a special
that's it could be of special sell that
I could sell me that could be special I
didn't like it and then because a mallet
comes in who's have been a boxer since
he was seven comes out of a wild card
and Floyd Mayweather's camp and he sees
wiry though you felt his strength a
little bit when you wiry
yeah why not strong compared to Brennan
shop no I thought you were being serious
a little bit you were like aw he's
strong and I thought maybe Brendan I'll
have a little trouble then I'm the big
boy then today boy you made me do it too
and Moloch couldn't like get your hands
on it but Marcos yeah let's do this
alike all right well Moloch wanted to
feel cuz now he's in as a pure boxer
he's into MMA and he wanted to feel what
it's like to get in the clutches of a
heavyweight and he didn't understand
what's going on you got him in the flop
on fluke show choke oh no cuz he grabbed
my neck
and I said you're gonna keep that
because I've seen this on UFC I went
okay hang on do it he was am i doing
right girl yeah man keep squeezing as
hard as you can drop to the side and
then I got me go to the side you still
got his eye it feels probably oh yeah
tighten it up tiny I live on flu choking
means what the [ __ ] he didn't know what
was going on because I didn't know what
was happening because that was [ __ ] up
he was talking to me we talked this
morning's talk to me about oh really
yeah you guys I don't know what the [ __ ]
that was I go now that's not that's
that's that's you got caught you got
caught up in you know he's a handsome
guy too
handsome guy though the ladies he's
looking at I'm like right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]